[Musique]
bonjour je suis Laurette Richard
fondateur de l'entreprise Lyca bossellé
une marque réunionnaise qui fait des
tablettes de chocolat à partir de fèves
de cacao donc c'est ce que l'on appelle
le Bintou bar en anglais
nous notre particularité chez les
cabosselés c'est qu'on fait du chocolat
noir à deux ingrédients donc il y a
uniquement de la fève de cacao et du
sucre pour le sucre on utilise bien
évidemment le sucre de la Réunion la
fève de cacao elle est super riche elle
contient une palette d'arôme et pour le
peu qu'on travaille correctement qu'on
soit bien ses fèves de cacao avec ses
agriculteurs on peut vous proposer un
produit unique notre produit Store le
voici donc c'est la tablette de chocolat
70-72% cacao de Bourbon on collecte les
cabosses auprès des agriculteurs on fait
les fermentations le séchage la
torréfaction etc jusqu'à obtenir obtenir
pardon une tablette qui a des notes de
fleurs de jasmin de miel et de biscuits
on est sur une variété qui s'appelle le
Criollo c'est une variété qui est de
plus en plus rare dans le monde on a
encore cette variété à la Réunion et
c'est ce qui nous permet aussi de mettre
en avant aujourd'hui au salon de
l'agriculture le terroir réunionnais à
travers cette tablette
l'idée pour les caboseller aujourd'hui
c'est de faire connaître un petit peu
plus la marque sur le sur le territoire
métropolitain idéalement on aimerait
bien quitter le salon avec de sérieux
contacts pour pouvoir exporter et faire
connaître notre chocolat pays à toute la
métropole